doing this thing I'm collecting a
question and then the next celebrity
that comes up I'm going to ask them your
question hey why aren't you left-handed
why am I not because I was born
right-handed and kind of ambidextrous
ass like it's like a bat left but I
write right
do you put bananas in your cereal for
breakfast yes I do
Milo that's amazing yeah often what was
the after party you almost didn't
survive my weddings after party I could
barely walk by the end and it wasn't
necessarily because of alcohol I was so
exhausted from celebrating and dancing
and shenanigans that yeah it was it was
but we survived we're here today rachel
is here somewhere is there a personal
item that you bring to things like this
that grounds you a Costco chicken I try
to stuff it in my clutch as I fold her
up how are you taped in I did I do I do
you some double-stick every once in a
while but I won't tell you where and how
how about that tell me one question you
would want to ask an actor here tonight
and I'm gonna ask the next person that
walks up on this platform that question
how much do you love that you know it's
literally in every fiber of my being
that's why I wake up and do what I do to
tell these stories of the ones who ever
missed welcome forward it's all the
stories and people that you have yet to
meet sort of people who may not have a
voice so all that is a lovely